[Musique]
fier
du soutien unanime de mon équipe hier
soir au conseil municipal et fort de ce
soutien pour aborder tous les grands
sujets et les grands projets que j'ai à
cœur de mettre à terme qui avait entamé
monsieur Müller j'ai hâte de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet en tant que mère
sachant que en tant que premier maire
adjoint de la ville d'épônes pendant 9
ans on a beaucoup œuvré également dans
ma délégation et au quotidien avec
Monsieur Muller
[Musique]
je pense que
la règle sera la continuité de notre
programme politique pour lesquels les
épaulois nous ont élus en 2020 et qui
ont élu notre groupe dynamique Épône
avec ma personnalité avec mes petites
différences avec Monsieur Muller
mais dans la dans le même esprit et
surtout dans la dans la même combativité
que jusqu'à présent
[Musique]
du centre-ville et la valorisation du
patrimoine pour accueillir de nouveaux
services et commerces c'est la
démolition reconstruction et
réhabilitation du quartier de la mairie
d'épônes la reconstruction du collège
des pônes
c'est la reconstruction et la création
du futur quartier Gare et Paul Mézières
le confortement de nos activités
économiques et des emplois proximité
renforcement humain et technique de la
police municipale au service des épaules
création d'équipements sportifs et
ludiques et de proximité
[Musique]